as part of the recent back to hogwarts
celebration hogwarts legacy just gave us
an absolutely stunning look at all of
the common rooms and here in today's
video we're gonna break down the
slytherin common room because there are
so many incredible details so many
things that i missed upon first viewing
even for just a little over a one minute
clip in fact i got a challenge for you
today let's see how many serpents you
can find throughout the video see if you
can find more than me i'm going to be
tracking them as we go because there are
a lot of serpents in the slytherin
common room surprise surprise right
there are 10 total scenes in all and
we're going to be going through them one
by one starting with this scene right
here and honestly you don't have to get
very far to start noticing some
interesting things i want to call your
attention to this i mean the very first
frame here in the bottom left corner
because this right here looks like some
sort of notice board to me now for those
of you who played the original harry
potter games one of the best things
about those games and they had their
highs and lows but one of the best
things about those games had to be the
notice board and if you didn't play them
basically the way it worked is on these
notice boards you could find notes left
behind by other students who were
missing certain items then as you're
going around and exploring the castle
you could find those items and return
them to the lost items message board for
rewards personally i think it would be
awesome if they brought back something
similar to this in hogwarts legacy and
right here at the bottom left corner
that just might be the hint we need to
start speculating even more now as for
the room itself there are a couple of
things that jump out at me right away we
know that the slytherin common room is
down in the dungeon so it makes sense to
see all of these stone structures almost
like they actually wanted to create the
effect that you were deep underground in
some sort of cave and who knows hogwarts
is built magically after all perhaps it
is even within part of the actual stone
of the surrounding area right here you
also have the stone columns and of
course we spot our first snake over here
on the right side of the screen just
above the fireplace another common theme
throughout the slytherin common room are
animal skulls you'll see a couple of
them along the right side of the wall
here there's also a student here in the
middle of the room that appears to be
reading a spell book and then we have a
tapestry of a wizard who i admittedly
have no idea who it is same thing for a
lot of these portraits if you guys spot
anyone famous or that we should know
from the books be sure and let me know
down in the comments below you'll see
the hourglass over here on the right
side of the screen another elaborate
tapestry here on the left as well as
another animal skull there and then our
first look at the staircase which i
presume leads into the boys and girls
dormitories here in slytherin house and
how could we not talk about the
slytherin statue there at the top of the
staircase we're gonna get an even closer
look at it here in just a second now i
came insanely close to missing the snake
over here on the left side have you
caught it yet well look right here in
this area i am pretty sure that that is
yet another snake that appears to be
maybe a handle on something that part's
a little bit harder to make out but i'm
almost positive that it is indeed
another serpent then we get an even
closer look at the fireplace and mantle
not gonna count that snake again because
we already counted him but we will count
the one on the right bringing our total
to three so far and i'm not really
seeing the head of a snake right here
but i'm pretty sure this is supposed to
be at least one snake so we'll go ahead
and call it one more and then right here
if you actually look inside the
fireplace yet another serpent icon there
bringing our total to five now even
though the slytherin common room is in
the dungeons you get a nice spacious
area right here with these amazing
windows looking directly out into the
black lake chandler wood even made the
comment about don't tap the glass which
you know has to do something now in game
right i mean does a mermaid pop up do we
see the giant squid something has to
happen when you go and tap the glass now
in hogwarts legacy still plenty of stone
in this room as well as the animal bones
over here on the right and then right
here in the center of the room is what
appears to be a mermaid it's not really
the bones of a mermaid is it a replica
of a mermaid or is it a fiji mermaid
that is something i had never heard of
before someone had posted it over on the
harry potter game subreddit and it's
kind of creepy actually which i suppose
would fit well here in the slytherin
common room but it's essentially the
torso and head of a juvenile monkey sewn
to the back half of a fish to give the
appearance of a mermaid so i don't know
why they need to do that in hogwarts
legacy because i mean mermaids are real
in this world the next one though by far
my favorite of the whole entire common
room reveal trailer the entrance and
guys on every test i have ever taken for
sorting in hogwarts legacy for sorting
in harry potter i am never slytherin it
is always the absolute lowest for me and
even as someone who hates snakes this is
absolutely incredible the entrance to
the slytherin common room amazing i also
have to make sure i point out the
hogwarts fanatic robe here sporting
slytherin house in this case you can get
this by linking your wizarding world
account to your wb account which will
also bring over your wand and house into
hogwarts legacy now in addition to the
giant stone snake that reveals the
entrance to the slytherin common room
there are some other things i love about
this shot too first the pattern on the
ground it's almost like this is a
marking this is an indicator to
slytherins that hey here's your common
room because it's very inconspicuous
right other students may pass by this
area and have no idea that that is the
entrance to the common room right there
and the pattern here at the bottom looks
a little bit like the merlin puzzles
that we saw not gonna say exactly but a
little bit and it would certainly fit
because merlin was in fact a slytherin
in the world of harry potter oh and i
think it's time to update our serpent
count again because it looks like we
have one two three here on the right and
one two three here on the left as well
that is six in this shot alone which
brings our total to eleven also have the
suit of armor over there on the right
wonder if they're gonna come alive at
any point in hogwarts legacy and then we
gotta watch it just one more time look
at the animation on this i mean i love
it you guys so eerie but just so fitting
for house slytherin and then let's talk
about this door right here because we
have even more snakes i know surprise
right well we gotta count the big snakes
so that's one more then we have two here
three here four here five here is that
it not so fast look at the top here six
and seven which brings our total to 18
snakes at this point in the next scene
we get another shot of the spacious
interior once again showing off the
black lake and are those telescopes i
see looking out into the water as the
scene shifts we get a closer look right
here and it does indeed look to be some
sort of telescope alright this right
here they are clearly wanting us to see
the wizards chess set that is sitting
right here on the table just begging to
be played now we don't get any sort of
interact prompt that shows up but man
this sure seems like a big hint fingers
crossed that wizard's chest will be a
playable mini-game in hogwarts legacy
also on the table we have some books as
well as an ink bottle and a quill and
just before it cuts away to another
scene take a look at the table over here
looks like there are three artifacts
here the one in the middle almost looks
like some sort of viking horn and the
one on the right looks as if it could be
a tiny owl yet it doesn't appear to be
moving what do you guys think any
guesses on this here and then just
before the scene cuts away over on the
right we can see a very large harp
perhaps this is the very same harp that
would one day be used to calm fluffy to
sleep as professor quirrell slash
voldemort made his way toward the
sorcerer's stone philosopher's stone
whatever in the next scene we're back in
a familiar room once again take note of
the cabinet here where you have even
more artifacts the one that caught my
attention right away is the one in the
top left corner is it possible this is a
container of skelegro here right here we
have a crystal ball perhaps this is a
spare for divination class couple of
other tribal looking artifacts a spell
book something that appears to be an egg
and then sitting ever so temptingly at
the top of the right side of the cabinet
what appears to be an ornate lockbox of
some sort couple of more animal skulls
here on the right then we make the turn
into a long hallway just before it
transitions to one of my favorite shots
of the whole trailer this one right here
at the bottom of the steps that lead off
to the dormitories complete with the
salazar slytherin statue at the top
right there in the middle you see we
have two serpents on either side of the
stairs as well as another serpent here
with salazar if you're still counting at
home that is 21 total serpents so far on
the left side we have a student carrying
a stack of books with some other flying
enchanted books behind him more animal
bones here and then here at the top left
what appears to be a ravenclaw crest
what do you guys think it could be doing
here in the slytherin common room and
then right before this scene transitions
away if you look on the right side
there's this shining blue dot it's only
a single one that i see so could this be
a conversation that we can interact with
or perhaps there's some sort of secret
item hidden and we're supposed to go
investigate now i believe this next
scene right here is actually showing
what it would look like for your
character to exit the common room
there's a gorgeous waterfall over here
on the right more stone as well as this
animal etched in the stone right here i
think this could be a statue of a zuwu
which is one of the creatures that was
featured prominently in the fantastic
beasts series and then right here i
think they're just flipping it around
and giving us one final look at what the
entrance to the slytherin common room
would look like and yep i see the snake
over there on the right i believe we've
already counted that one though which is
going to bring my total to 21 total
serpents did i get them all or did you
guys find even more i guess it could
actually be 22 if you count the one on
the back of the robes of course
slytherin is just one of the common
rooms and guys they all truly do look
incredible up next i'm gonna break down
the gryffindor common room as soon as
that video is ready it'll be on the
right side of your screen now check it
out as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon